special counsel robber Muller's final
report on the Russia investigation could
be handed in within days we don't know
about how much of it will be revealed to
the public president Trump was asked
about it yesterday
mr. president should the mother report
be released while you're abroad next
week that'll be totally up to the new
Attorney General he's a tremendous man a
tremendous person who really respects
this country and respects the Justice
Department so that'll be totally up to
him well major Garrett is at the White
House with new information major good
morning what do we know good morning the
special counsels investigation is
clearly winding down and two sources
close to the matter tell us that
Muller's report could be delivered as
early as tomorrow and certainly no later
than midnight latter date coinciding
with the departure of a key figure in
all this the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein the consensus Muller's report
is coming the precise timing of its
arrival however we should emphasize
remains speculative now once that report
arrives Attorney General William bar
will decide how much will be made public
there's no legal requirement for bar to
release any of the Mullen report
congressional Democrats at therefore
concerned bar will choose to limit the
release of the reports underlying
details at his confirmation hearing last
month Barr said he would make as much of
the report public as he could Barr has
indicated he might send a summary of
Muller's report to Congress leaving out
people who were not charged now the
president's legal team fully expects mr.
Trump to be cleared in all this though
the cases related to the underlying
Russian investigation quite obviously
will continue if congressional Democrats
are dissatisfied with what Barr submits
they could choose to subpoena the
special counsel to testify john the long
wait is almost over thank you so much
major